hello and welcome to maths simplified a
channel where we make biology and
medicine simple in this video we are
going to learn about the structure and
function of a nephron nephron is the
basic functional unit of the kidneys
that consists of a renal corpuscle and
the tubular attached to it the word
nephron is derived from the Greek word
Neph ROS meaning kidney each kidney
contains approximately 1 million
nephrons which performs several
important functions of her body
including waste excretion maintaining
the body's pH regulation of blood
pressure and several other functions so
let's go through the structure and
function of a nephron and learn more in
detail about the different parts of
nephron and the role of renal tubules in
urine formation and excretion process
you
let's first start with the basic
structure of a nephron so nephrons are
microscopic structures located in the
kidney and kidney has two important
gross regions and outer cortex and an
inner medulla and if you look at this
nephron you can see that a part of this
nephron is present in the cortex of the
kidney and part of this nephron is
placed in the medulla of the kidney this
is an important point to remember as it
plays a significant role in the
formation of urine that we will discuss
later in this video
so the nephron is a tube-like structure
whose length varies from 35 to 55
millimeters and the structure of nephron
can be basically divided into two major
portions the Bowman's capsule
and the renal tubule
at one end the tube is closed folded and
expanded into a cup like structure which
is known as the Bowman's capsule now the
Bowman's capsule was discovered by this
guy Sir Williams woman at the age of 25
he was an English surgeon and
histologies who is also credited with
the publication's of two historical
books the physiological anatomy and
physiology of man encyclopedia of
anatomy and physiology so coming back to
the nephron we discussed about the cup
shaped structure at one end which is
known as the Bowman's capsule the space
inside the Bowman's capsule is known as
the Bowman's space the Bowman's capsule
encloses a cluster of blood vessels
which is known as the glomerulus the
world glomerulus is derived from the
Latin word glue mer
meaning a ball of thread so you can see
why this is known as a glomerulus the
blood vessel which brings the blood
inside the glomerulus is known as the
afferent vessel and the blood vessel
taking the blood out of the glomerulus
is known as the efferent vessel remember
a comes before E so afferent brings the
blood in and afferent takes the blood
out the Bowman's capsule and clue
marilla's together constitute the renal
corpuscle
okay so this was about one end of the
nephron the other end is known as a
renal tubules the word to view just
means a small tube and as you can see
the renal tubules is a long and folded
tube like structure that emerges from
the Bowman's capsule at one end and it
ends into the duct system of the kidney
the tube you'll is divided into three
main parts based on its function the
proximal convoluted tubule which is this
part of the tube you'll shown in the
light blue color then we have the loop
of Henle which is shown in dark blue
color and finally we have the distal
convoluted tubules which is this part of
tubular shown in orange color the distal
convoluted tubules in turn ends into the
collecting duct
so the first part of the Tokyo is known
as the proximal convoluted tubule
proximal because it is close to the
Bowman's capsule and convoluted meaning
it is a highly folded structure that
helps to increase the overall length of
the tube you'll in a small space the
proximal tubules is located in the
cortex of the kidney the proximal
tubules to the loop of Henle which is
the second main part of the renal
tubules this region forms a loop that is
located in the renal medulla the loop
has a descending limb and an ascending
limb the ascending limb of loop of Henle
leads into the distal convoluted tubule
distal meaning away since it is located
far from the Bowman's capsule as
compared to the proximal tubules and
convoluted since it is also folded
structure to increase the overall length
of the tubular the distal convoluted
tubule drains into the collecting duct
which also receives input from many
other nephrons in the region the
collecting duct drains into the larger
collecting ducts and ultimately into the
renal pelvis which is connected to the
ureter the ureter drains the kidney to
the bladder the distal convoluted
tubules is also located in the cortex of
the kidney
now depending upon the length of the
loop of Henle we have two types of
nephrons in the kidney one type of
nephron that have short loops of Henle
and these are known as the short
cortical nephrons cortical because a
major portion of these nephrons is
located in the cortex of the kidney
these are short and comprise about 80%
of the total nephrons the other type of
nephrons that we have in our kidney are
known as the juxta medullary nephrons
which have long loops of Henley that are
mostly present in the medulla of the
kidney these two types of nephrons can
concentrate urine up to different
osmolarity
that we will discuss when we talk about
the function of nephron these are 20% in
number
along the whole length of the nephron
runs this network of small blood vessels
known as capillaries that brings in
impure blood containing many wastes
metabolic products and takes out pure
blood that has been filtered by the
nephron the impure blood or the arterial
blood comes into the kidney by the renal
artery and the pure blood which has been
filtered of all the metabolic and other
waste products goes back to the body by
other renal vein so this was about the
structure of nephron next let's have a
look at its basic function so the
nephron uses four main mechanisms to
convert blood into urine which are
filtration reabsorption secretion and
excretion now I have seen most of the
biology teachers here on YouTube and
what they do is they just explain what
is filtration what is reabsorption
what is secretion and job done this is
how urine is formed well not quite right
see in this video we will understand the
mechanism of your information in a
better way we will look at how the blood
is filtered at the level of renal
corpuscle and then we will understand
how the urine moves forward in the renal
tubules and how different mechanisms
like reabsorption and secretion apply in
different parts of the renal tubules so
the blood enters the kidney via the
renal artery this is a large artery and
a branch of Volta
after entering the kidney the renal
artery gets divided into many small
divisions until it reaches the smallest
one that enters the nephron this is the
efferent vessel that brings the blood
into the glomerulus and this is the
blood vessel that takes the blood out of
Rome areolas and this is known as the
efferent blood vessel in between these
afferent and efferent blood vessels is a
jumble of mass of capillaries that is
known as a glomerulus like we discussed
earlier glomerulus is derived from the
world bloomer which means a ball of
thread the glomerulus is a tuft of blood
vessels that is located inside the
Bowman's capsule this tuft of vessels
greatly increases the surface area for
filtration that comes in contact with
the Bowman's capsule and this is where
the
mechanism of your information takes
place that is known as the filtration
and understand the filtration at their
side you have to know a little bit about
the glomerular filtration barrier
so if you take this part of the renal
corpuscle and look at its microscopic
view it would look something like this
this is the wall of the blood vessel
outside this is the basement membrane of
the glomerulus which is in contact with
the wall of the Bowman's capsule the
wall of the Bowman's capsule contains
special type of cells which are known as
podocytes and between these photo sites
we have small caps as you can see and
these are known as the filtration slits
together these three layers form the
glomerular filtration barrier that acts
like a filter paper
so we have blood coming in in this blood
vessel that gets filtered through this
glomerular filtration barrier to form
the impure plasma that is passed down
into the union-tribune the glomerular
blood pressure provides the driving
force for water and solutes to be
filtered out of the blood plasma and
into the interior of the Bowman's
capsule called the Bowman's space only
about 1/5 of the plasma is filtered in
the glomerulus and the rest passes into
the efferent arteriole the things that
do not get filtered are things like red
blood cells or larger molecules like
proteins also one important thing you
should note here is a difference in the
diameter of the afferent and the
efferent blood vessel as you can see the
efferent vessel is of smaller diameter
as compared to the efferent vessel which
means that the blood is coming in
through a vessel of larger diameter and
leaving through a vessel of smaller
diameter this increases the pressure
inside the glomerulus which provides a
driving force which makes this
filtration possible the kidneys can
adjust the rate of glomerular filtration
by adjusting the pressure inside the
glomerulus and this is all possible
because a diameter of afferent and
efferent blood vessels can be adjusted
the plasma that gets filtered into the
Bowman's space is known as the
glomerular filtrate the glomerular
filtrate next moves into the renal
tubules where it is further processed to
form urine this further processing is
very important as an initial glomerular
fluid that is filtered into the Bowman's
space contains a lot of things that
shouldn't be excreted out with urine
like sodium chloride glucose amino acids
and excess water the first part of in LD
Buell is the proximal convoluted tubule
where approximately two-thirds of the
filtered salts and water almost all
glucose and amino acids are reabsorbed
we don't want to lose glucose that's
hard-earned stuff that we ate that was
good for energy we don't want to lose
necessarily as much sodium chloride as
well this is achieved by the method of a
reabsorption
the whole length of the renal tubule is
surrounded with blood vessels which are
known as the peritubular capillaries
whatever that gets reabsorbed is then
passed back into the blood circulation
now this is known as a reabsorption and
not absorption because the same
nutrients have been absorbed once from
your gut into your blood by the similar
mechanism the wall of the renal tubules
has many types of protein channels that
reabsorb some of the important things
that shouldn't be excreted with urine
now about 70 percent of sodium chloride
gets reabsorbed in the proximal
convoluted tubules and same 70 percent
water gets reabsorbed here and more than
95 percent of glucose and amino acids
get reabsorbed in the proximal
convoluted tubule
next the filtrate passes into the loop
of Henle the loop of Henle has some role
in reabsorption of important salts like
about 25% of sodium gets reabsorbed here
similarly 25% of calcium 20% of
potassium and about 60% of magnesium
gets reabsorbed in the loop of Henle but
the loop of Henle has a major role in
the concentration of urine and this is a
complex topic and usually taught at the
level of med school physiology but I'll
try to simplify this as much as possible
so pay close attention so here is our
section of kidney and you can see how
the structure of kidney is divided into
an outer cortex and an inner medulla the
inner medulla of the kidney is a very
important region as this contains higher
concentration of salts as compared to
the cortex of the kidney this higher
concentration of salts in the medulla is
made possible by the loop of Henle of
nephrons so here is our nephron inside
the kidney and you can see how this loop
of Henle is present inside the medulla
of the kidney and the rest of the
nephron is present up in the outer
cortex the loop of Henle has a
descending limb and an ascending limb so
if you look at the ascending limb of
loop of Henle it contains special ion
channels that pump out ions like sodium
and chloride thus making the renal
medulla more salty or hypertonic the
ascending limb however does not allow
water to move out as it has no channels
in its wall that allow the water to move
out these types of channels that allow
water to move out are known as the
aquaporins and these type of channels
are actually present in the descending
limb of loop of Henle that makes it
freely permeable to water so now this is
all salty and the water will move out of
the descending limb into the renal
medulla and then eventually into the
blood vessels and gets reabsorbed and
this is the reason why loop of Henle is
so long that is to give time for this
water to secrete out and that is why it
dips nice and pretty far down into this
salty portion which is the renal medulla
so this is the major mechanism of
gaining back a lot of water that gets
filtered up at the level of renal
corpuscle so after the loop of Henle the
water then passes into the distal
convoluted tubules which is this part of
the renal tubules and here we have more
reabsorption of ions like calcium and
sodium
we are just reabsorbing more things that
we didn't want to lose in the first
place
there's a lot of things we could talk
about what gets reabsorbed here but this
is just the overview in distal
convoluted tubules
the final mechanism of urine formation
also takes place that is known as
secretion you can view secretion as the
opposite of reabsorption in secretion
the waste ions and hydrogen ions pass
from the capillaries into the renal
tubules
this is the final step in the formation
of urine during which walls of the tube
you'll actively remove waste substances
which are harmful to the body from the
blood that have escaped filtration the
secreted ions combined with the
remaining filtrate and become urine the
major substances secreted into the
distal convoluted tubules include
hydrogen ions potassium ions and
ammonium ions the mechanism secretion
also takes place in the proximal
convoluted tubules but to a lesser
extent and some important stuff that
gets secreted into the proximal
convoluted tubules
include substances like urea uric acid
creatine ammonium ions and some other
drugs
then at the end right here we have our
filtrate that has been processed a lot
of water has been taken out it's a lot
more concentrated we have reabsorbed a
lot of salts electrolytes and we have
reabsorbed all the glucose and amino
acids that we could this waste fluid
then gets dumped into the collecting
duct you can see the collecting ducts
like a common drain pipe that collects
waste from all the houses in the
neighborhood except in this case where
this pipe is the collecting duct and the
houses are individual nephrons the
collecting duct is important
functionally from two aspects first it
dips back into the medulla and second
because antidiuretic hormone acts on our
collecting ducts to decide whether our
urine should be concentrated or diluted
the function of antidiuretic hormone is
a whole different topic that we will
discuss in some future video the urine
in each collecting duct is drained into
the renal pelvis which is this dilated
portion of the kidney that is in turn
connected to the ureters the ureters
connect the kidney to the urinary
bladder that is connected to the urethra
now to learn more about the urethra and
all the other organs of human excretion
watch this upcoming video on our channel
about a human excretory system I hope
you liked the video and if you did
kindly support us by linking this video
and sharing with your friends thank you
so much for watching subscribe to
support our Channel